past and future in the unconscious so
far I have been sketching some of the
principles on which I approached the
problem of dreams for when we want to
investigate man's faculty to produce
symbols dreams proved to be the most
basic and accessible material for this
purpose the two fundamental points in
dealing with dreams are these first the
dream should be treated as a fact about
which one must make no previous
assumption except that it somehow makes
sense and second the dream is a specific
expression of the unconscious one could
scarcely put these principles more
modestly no matter how low anyone's
opinion of the unconscious may be he
must concede that it is worth
investigating the unconscious is at
least on a level with the Laois which
after all enjoys the Honest interest of
the entomologist if somebody with little
experience and knowledge of dreams
thinks that dreams are just chaotic
occurrences without meaning he is at
liberty to do so but if one assumes that
they are normal events which is a matter
of fact they are one is bound to
consider that they are either causal
that is that there is a rational cause
for their existence or in a certain way
purposive or both let us now look a
little more closely at the ways in which
the conscious and unconscious contents
of the mind are linked together take an
example with which everyone is familiar
suddenly you find you cannot remember
what you were going to say next though a
moment ago the thought was perfectly
clear or perhaps you were about to
introduce a friend and his name escaped
you as you were about to utter it you
say you cannot remember in fact though
the thought has become unconscious or at
least momentarily separated from
consciousness we find the same
phenomenon with our senses if we listen
to a continuous note on the fringe of
audibility the sound seems to stop at
regular intervals and then start again
such oscillations are due to a periodic
decrease and increase in one's attention
not to any change in the note but when
something slips out of our consciousness
it does
not ceased to exist any more than a car
that has disappeared round a corner has
vanished into thin air it is simply out
of sight just as we may later see the
car again so we come across thoughts
that were temporarily lost to us thus
part of the unconscious consists of a
multitude of temporarily obscured
thoughts impressions and images that in
spite of being lost continue to
influence our conscious minds a man who
is distracted or absent-minded will walk
across the room to fetch something
he stops seemingly perplexed he is
forgotten what he was after his hands
grope about among the objects on the
table as if he were sleepwalking he is
oblivious of his original purpose yet he
is unconsciously guided by it then he
realizes what it is that he wants his
unconscious has prompted him if you
observe the behavior of a neurotic
person you can see him doing many things
that he appears to be doing consciously
and purposefully yet if you ask him
about them you will discover that he is
either unconscious of them or has
something quite different in mind he
hears and does not hear he sees it is
blind he knows and is ignorant such
examples are so common that the
specialist soon realizes that
unconscious contents of the mind behave
as if they were conscious and that you
can never be sure in such cases where
the thoughts speech or action is
conscious or not it is this kind of
behavior that makes so many physicians
dismiss statements by hysterical
patients as utter lies such persons
certainly produce more on truths than
most of us but lie is scarcely the right
word to use in fact their mental state
causes an uncertainty of behavior
because their consciousness is liable to
unpredictable Eclipse by an interference
from the unconscious even their skin
sensations may reveal similar
fluctuations of awareness at one moment
the hysterical person may feel a needle
prick in the arm at the next it may pass
unnoticed if his attention can be
focused on a certain point the whole of
his body can be completely anesthetized
and to
the tension that causes this blackout of
the senses has been relaxed sense
perception is then immediately restored
all the time however he has been
unconsciously aware of what was
happening the physician can see this
process quite clearly when he hypnotizes
such a patient it is easy to demonstrate
that the patient has been aware of every
detail the prick in the arm where the
remark made during an eclipse of
consciousness can be recalled as
accurately as if there had been no
anesthesia or forgetfulness I recall a
woman who was once admitted to the
clinic in a state of complete stupor
when she recovered consciousness next
day she knew who she was but did not
know where she was how or why she had
come there or even the date yet after I
had hypnotized her she told me why she
had fallen ill how she had got to the
clinic and who had admitted her all
these details could be verified she was
even able to tell the time at which she
had been admitted because she had seen a
clock in the entrance hall under
hypnosis her memory was as clear as if
she had been completely conscious all
the time when we discussed such matters
we usually have to draw on evidence
supplied by clinical observation for
this reason many critics assume that the
unconscious and all its subtle
manifestations belong solely to the
sphere of psychopathology they consider
any expression of the unconscious as
something neurotic or psychotic which
has nothing to do with a normal mental
state but neurotic phenomena are by no
means the products exclusively of
disease they are in fact no more than
pathological exaggerations of normal
occurrences it is only because they are
exaggerations that they are more obvious
than their normal counterparts
hysterical symptoms can be observed in
all normal persons but they are so
slight that they usually pass unnoticed
forgetting for instance is a normal
process in which certain conscious ideas
lose their specific energy because one's
attention has been deflected when
interest turns elsewhere it leaves in
shadow the things with which one was
previously concerned just as a
searchlight lights up a new area by
leave
another in darkness this is unavoidable
for consciousness can keep only a few
images in full clarity at one time and
even this clarity fluctuates but the
Forgotten ideas have not ceased to exist
although they cannot be reproduced at
will they are present in a subliminal
state just beyond the threshold of
recall from which they can rise again
spontaneously at any time often after
many years of apparently total oblivion
I am speaking here of things we have
consciously seen or heard and
subsequently forgotten but we all see
hear smell and taste many things without
noticing them at the time either because
our attention is deflected or because
the stimulus to our senses is too slight
to leave a conscious impression the
unconscious however has taken note of
them and such subliminal sense
perceptions play a significant part in
our everyday lives without our realizing
it they influence the way in which we
react to both events and people an
example of this that I found
particularly revealing was provided by a
professor who had been walking in the
country with one of his pupils absorbed
in serious conversation suddenly he
noticed that his thoughts were being
interrupted by an unexpected flow of
memories from his early childhood he
could not account for this distraction
nothing in what had been said seemed to
have any connection with these memories
on looking back he saw that he had been
walking past a farm when the first of
these childhood recollections had surged
up in his mind he suggested to his pupil
that they should walk back to the point
where the fantasies had begun once there
he noticed the smell of geese and
instantly he realized that it was this
smell that had touched off the flow of
memories in his youth he had lived on a
farm where geese were kept and their
characteristic smell had left a lasting
though forgotten impression as he passed
the farm on his walk he had noticed the
smell subliminally and this unconscious
perception had called back
long-forgotten experiences of his
childhood the perception was subliminal
because the attention was engaged
elsewhere and the stimulus was now
strong enough to deflect it and to reach
consciousness directly yet it had
brought up the forgotten memories such a
queue or trigger effect can explain the
onset of neurotic symptoms as well as
more benign memories when a sight smell
or sound recalls a circumstance in the
past a girl for instance may be busy in
her office
apparently in good health and spirits a
moment later she develops a blinding
headache and shows other signs of
distress without consciously noticing it
she has heard the foghorn of a distant
ship and this is unconsciously reminded
her of an unhappy parting with a lover
whom she has been doing her best to
forget aside from normal forgetting
Freud has described several cases that
involve the forgetting of disagreeable
memories memories that one is only too
ready to lose as Nietzsche remarked
where pride is insistent enough memory
prefers to give way thus among the lost
memories we encounter not a few that oh
they're subliminal state and their
incapacity to be voluntarily reproduced
to their disagreeable and incompatible
nature the psychologist calls these
repressed contents a case in point might
be that of a secretary who is jealous of
one of her employers associates
she habitually forgets to invite this
person to meetings though the name is
clearly marked on the list she is using
but if challenged on the point she
simply said as she forgot or was
interrupted she never admits not even to
herself the real reason for her omission
many people mistakenly overestimate the
role of willpower and think that nothing
can happen to their minds that they do
not decide and intend but one must learn
to discriminate carefully between
intentional and unintentional contents
of the mind the former are derived from
the ego personality the latter however
arise from a source that is not
identical with the ego but is its other
side it is this other side that would
have made the secretary forget the
invitations there are many reasons why
we forget things that we have noticed or
experience and there are just as many
ways and we
they may be recalled to mind an
interesting example is that of Krypton
IVA or concealed recollection an author
may be writing steadily to a
preconceived plan working out an
argument or developing the line of the
story when he suddenly runs off at a
tangent perhaps a fresh idea has
occurred to him or a different image or
a whole new subplot if you ask him what
prompted the digression he will not be
able to tell you
he may not even have noticed the change
though he has now produced material that
is entirely fresh and apparently unknown
to him before yet it can sometimes be
shown convincingly that what he is
written there's a striking similarity to
the work of another author a work that
he believes he has never seen I myself
found a fascinating example of this in
Nietzsche's book thus spake Zarathustra
where the author reproduces almost
word-for-word an incident reported in a
ship's log for the year 1686 by sheer
chance I had read this seaman's yarn in
a book published about 1835 half a
century before Nietzsche wrote and when
I found the similar passage in the spake
Zarathustra I was struck by its peculiar
style which was different from
Nietzsche's usual language I was
convinced that Nietzsche must also have
seen the old book though he made no
reference to it I wrote to his sister
who was still alive and she confirmed
that she and her brother had in fact
read the book together when he was 11
years old I think from the context it is
inconceivable that Nietzsche had any
idea that he was plagiarizing this story
I believe that 50 years later it had
unexpectedly slipped into focus in his
conscious mind note Nietzsche's Krypton
eva is discussed in Jung's on the
psychology of so-called occult phenomena
in collected works Volume one the
relevant passage from the ship's log and
the corresponding passage from Nietzsche
are as follows from jkerner
letter Osprey Vorst volume 4 page 57
headed an extract of our inspiring
import
originally 1831 237 the four captains
and the merchant mr. Bell went ashore on
the island of Mount Stromlo Lee to shoot
rabbits at 3 o'clock they mustered the
crew to go aboard when to their
inexpressible astonishment they saw two
men flying rapidly toward them through
the air one was dressed in black the
other in gray they came past them very
closely in greatest haste and to their
utmost dismay descended into the crater
of the terrible volcano Mount Stromboli
they recognized the pair as
acquaintances from London from F
Nietzsche thus spake Zarathustra chapter
40 great events translated by common
page 180 slightly modified originally
1883 now about the time that Zarathustra
sojourned on the Happy Isles it happened
that a ship anchored at the Isle on
which the smoking Mountain stand and the
crew went ashore to shoot rabbits about
the noontide hour however when the
captain and his men were together again
they suddenly saw a man coming toward
them through the air and the voice said
distinctly it is time it is highest time
but when the figure drew close to them
flying past quickly like a shadow in the
direction of the volcano
they recognized with the greatest dismay
that it was arethusa
behold to the old helmsman Zarathustra
goes down to hell end of note in this
type of case there is genuine if
unrealized recollection much the same
sort of thing may happen to a musician
who has heard a peasant tune or popular
song in childhood and finds it cropping
up as the theme of a symphonic movement
that he is composing in adult life an
idea or an image has moved back from the
unconscious into the conscious mind what
I have so far said about the unconscious
is no more than a cursory sketch of the
nature and functioning of this complex
part of the human psyche but it should
have indicated the kind of subliminal
material from which
the symbols of our dreams may be
spontaneously produced this subliminal
material can consist of all urges
impulses and intentions all perceptions
and intuitions all rational or
irrational thoughts conclusions
inductions deductions and premises and
all varieties of feeling any or all of
these can take the form of partial
temporary or constant unconsciousness
such material has mostly become
unconscious because in a manner of
speaking there is no room for it in the
conscious mind some of one's thoughts
lose their emotional energy and become
subliminal that is to say they no longer
receive so much of our conscious
attention because they have come to seem
uninteresting or irrelevant or because
there is some reason why we wish to push
them out of sight it is in fact normal
and necessary for us to forget in this
fashion in order to make room in our
conscious Minds for new impressions and
ideas if this did not happen everything
we experienced would remain above the
threshold of consciousness and our minds
would become impossibly cluttered this
phenomenon is so widely recognized today
that most people who know anything about
psychology take it for granted but just
as conscious contents can vanish into
the unconscious new contents which have
never yet been conscious can arise from
it one may have an inkling for instance
that something is on the point of
breaking into consciousness that
something is in the air or that one
smells a rat the discovery that the
unconscious is no mere depository of the
past but is also full of germs of future
psychic situations and ideas led me to
my own new approach to psychology a
great deal of controversial discussion
has arisen around this point but it is a
fact that in addition to memories from a
long distant conscious past completely
new thoughts and creative ideas can also
present themselves from the unconscious
thoughts and ideas that have never been
conscious before they grow up from the
dark depths of the mind like a lotus and
form a most important part of the
subliminal psyche we find this in
everyday life
where
are sometimes solved by the most
surprising new propositions many artists
philosophers and even scientists Oh some
of their best ideas - inspirations that
appear suddenly from the unconscious the
ability to reach a rich vein of such
material and to translate it effectively
into philosophy literature music or
scientific discovery is one of the
hallmarks of what is commonly called
genius we can find clear proof of this
fact in the history of science itself
for example the French mathematician
pong cafe and the chemist Kaku lay or
the important scientific discoveries as
they themselves admit to sudden
pictorial revelations from the
unconscious the so-called mystical
experience of the French philosopher
Descartes involved a similar sudden
revelation in which he saw in a flash
the order of all Sciences the British
author Robert Louis Stevenson had spent
years looking for a story that would fit
his strong sense of man's double being
when the part of dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
was suddenly revealed to him in a dream
later I shall describe in more detail
how such material arises from the
unconscious and I shall examine the form
in which it is expressed at the moment I
simply want to point out that the
capacity of the human psyche to produce
such new material is particularly
significant when one is dealing with
dream symbolism for I have found again
and again in my professional work that
the images and ideas that dreams contain
cannot possibly be explained solely in
terms of memory they express new
thoughts that have never yet reached the
threshold of consciousness